what is this try not to crimes challenge
oh god I get I better get some help I'm
here no not you go back okay fine fine
mine says a year trying to cringe
challenge the one person that I've never
seen cringe it's you
you don't crane yeah but you're the
craziest girlfriend ever
thank you this has been character ID'd
by Kirsten Dunst rainbow sucks yeah just
your trigger me please this is cringe
come you're making this a cringe
compilation let's do this finish actor
attempts backflip on talk show with the
other cool is escalating with finish
people he's gonna do it yeah me do the
backplate sweating you don't care why I
just lay there you serious okay fine
next one okay cringed nut creams okay
Hawaii from Hawaii to away we are truly
the land of the great from the rocky
shores of Hawaii to the beautiful sandy
beaches of Hawaii America is our home
what did she just say no way from the
rocky shores of Hawaii really this would
kill me for years I would have to go to
therapy
are you serious from the rocky shores to
Hawaii to the beaches of how are you
serious
how are you not destroyed very nervous
you're too compassionate Oh Lucas conga
happy yeah how do you not realize it's
not fine
Hey no I he would mmm
next one women treat me how are your
gonna crunch by then is all right I
promise you
women calls LeBron James a crybaby and
then gets caught
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Oh deserve it that's what you get for
being me person next video give me
something stronger
give us something stronger we need that
cranes come on very well
princess as you wish
[Music]
[Applause]
she just wanted a live-in tell me that
wasn't great yeah a little bit three
more chances for you to cringe I am I
Philly I'm in pain this is agony yeah
joke - Dalai Lama goes awkward so the
Dalai Lama walks into a pizza shop cause
I felt Pizza Pizza Pizza shop and says
can you make me one with everything
what's that can you make me one with
everything
no cringe Oh what because even that
happened to me that's why I never say
jokes I can now yeah puns should just be
thrown in a pit of fire and never be
used final one Ryan Seacrest
high fives blind guy don't never - never
handshake Paul never hug
congratulations Oh No NEA I feel awful
how do you feel I mean I feel bad for
all these people you know some are funny
it's not making me look bad
okay this has been the critic challenge
thank you for watching this video if you
enjoyed leave it like it let us know
what challenge you want to do next and
as always all right look at me win a
closer what he's clearly a pet oh my god